this is a video for the measuring angles
module because clearly at the time that
I'm doing this video there is no video
for the measuring angles module this is
a pretty neat module this was made by
Omar Rizvan someone of our are amazing
high school interns that we had this
past summer in the summer of 2011 and
what it really is is it makes you
measure angles and he made this really
cool protractor tool here so that you
actually used this protractor to measure
the angles there and so the trick here
is you would actually measure the way
you would measure any any angle using an
actual physical protractor you'd want to
put the center of the protractor right
at the vertex of where the two lines
intersect you can kind of view it as the
vertex of the angle and then you'd want
to rotate it so that preferably this
edge this edge at zero degrees is that
one of is that one of these is it one of
these sides so let's do it so that this
edge right over here is is right along
this line so let me rotate it so then
I'm going to rotate a little bit further
that looks maybe maybe one more that's
too far so that looks about right and
then if you if you look at it this way
you can see that the angle and I don't
have my pen tool here I'm just using my
regular web browser if you look at the
angle here you see that the other line
goes to 130 degrees so this angle that's
what that we need to measure here is 130
degrees assuming you can read sideways
so that is 130 degrees let me check my
answer very good I got it right it would
be embarrassing if I didn't let's do the
next question I'll do a couple of
examples like this so once again let us
put the center of the protractor right
at the vertex right over there and let's
get this zero degree side to be on one
of the sides so that this angle will
kind of be within the protractor so let
me rotate it this way and this really is
pretty cool what Omar did with this
module so let's see let's do it see one
more time that's too far so that looks
about right and then you can see that
the angle right over here it is if we
look at where the other line points to
it is 40 degrees
it is 40 degrees check answer very good
let's do another one this is fun all
right so let's get our protractor right
over there you don't always have to do
in that same order you could rotate it
first so that the zero degrees is all
you want to do is you want to rotate the
zero degrees to one of the sides but so
that the angle is still within the
protractor so let's rotate it around so
if you did it like that so you don't
always have to do it in that same order
although I think it's easier to rotate
it when you have the center of the
protractor at the vertex of the angle so
we have to rotate it a little bit more
so this is zero degrees is this line and
then we as we go further and further up
I guess since this is on the side looks
like this other line gets us to 150
degrees and hopefully you're noticing
that the higher to the degrees the more
open this angle is and so this one right
over here is 150 degrees and so let's do
that
150 let's do one more now let me show
you what not to do so what not to do is
so you could put the you could put the
center right over there and you might
say okay let me put let me make the zero
go right over on this side right over
here so if you did that if you did that
notice your angle would not be within
the protractor so you won't be able to
measure it and what you're attempting to
do is measure this outer angle over here
which is an angle but that's not the
angle that this question is asking us to
measure this little arc over here is
telling us that that's the angle that we
need to measure so that arc has to be
within the protractor so let's rotate
this protractor a little bit more I
overdid it and so this looks like this
is zero degrees and then this right over
here is 60 degrees 60 degrees we got
that one right - so hopefully that that
helps you with this module that it's
kind of kind of fun